life did not intend to make us perfect
whoever is perfect belongs in a museum
modesty and conscientiousness
receive their reward only in novels
in life they are exploited
and then shoved aside
to forget is the secret of eternal youth
one grows old only through memory
there's much too little forgetting
he who wants to hold on to that is
losing
those who are ready to let go with a
smile are trying to keep him
the more primitive a man is
the better he believes himself to be
the first person you think of in the
morning and the last person you think at
night
is either the cause of your happiness
or the cause of your pain
not always sorry for the one who was
wrong
asking forgiveness of the one who values
the relations
i feel like i'm among people who are
going to live forever
at least that is how they act
they are so obsessed with money that
they have forgotten about life
anything
you can settle with money
is cheap
the best way to lose a woman
was to show her a kind of life that one
could offer her for only a few days
you may turn into an archangel a fool
or a criminal
no one will see it
but when a button is missing
everyone sees that
[Music]
never do anything complicated when
something simple will serve as well
it's one of the most important secrets
of living
a man only begins to be valued when he
is no longer there
it is better to die when i want to live
than to live before you want to die
what you can't get always seems better
than what you have
this includes the romance and idiocy of
human life
if a woman belongs to another man
she is five times more desirable than
the one you can easily get
strange how complicated we can make
things just to avoid showing what we
feel
whatever happens to you
never take it personally
nothing in this world is so important
i stood next to her
listened to her
laughed and thought how terrible it is
to love a woman and be poor
only when you finally part with a person
you begin to be truly interested in
everything that concerns him
this is one of the paradoxes of love
it is a mistake to assume that all
people have the same ability to feel
a man is always great in his intentions
however
not in their fulfillment
therein lies his fascination
[Music]
there is nothing more tiring than to
attend how a person demonstrates his
mind
in particular
if there is no mind
a person can become close to you in
three days
and the one who lives near you for years
may never know what your favorite color
is
[Music]
women do not need to explain anything
you always have to act with them
a woman should not tell a man that she
loves him
let her shining happy eyes speak about
this
they are more eloquent than any words
only a complete idiot would argue with a
woman and appeal to her logic
a lonely person cannot be abandoned
being in love
is when you want to get old with someone
it's only terrible to have nothing to
wait for
it is very clear that the unhappiness of
the world is so often brought on by
small men
we are forlorn like children
and experienced like old men
we are crude and sorrowful and
superficial
we are lost
keep things at arm's length
if you let anything come too near
you want to hold on to it
and there is nothing a man can hold on
to
life is a disease
and death begins already at birth
every breath
every heartbeat
is a moment of dying
a little shove toward the end
we have so much to say
and we shall never say it
bombardment barrage
curtain fire
mines gas tanks machine guns
hand grenades
words
words
but they hold the horror of the world
it was a melancholy secret
that reality can arouse desires but
never satisfy them
at school
nobody ever taught us how to light a
cigarette in a storm of rain
nor how a fire could be made with wet
wood
nor that it is best to stick a bayonet
in the belly
because there it doesn't get jammed as
it does in the ribs
if a woman saves money on herself
it means that it makes men want to save
money on her
our knowledge of life is limited to
death
everyone saves someone at least once
just as he kills someone at least once
even though he may not know it
if a woman is angry it means she is
not only wrong
but also
she knows it
no soldier outlives a thousand chances
but every soldier believes in chance
and trusts his luck
a woman becomes smarter when she is in
love
whereas a man loses his mind
what comfort there is in the skin of
someone you love
good or ill
life is life
you only realize that
when you have to risk it
who has many women
knows women
who has one wife
knows love
a friend standing behind
is worse than an enemy standing in front
if a man is not married at 30
it means that he has not been forced to
get married yet
men don't get married because they want
to get married
but because women want to get married
the things men did or felt they had to
do
love should not be polluted with
friendship
no one could become stranger than the
person you once loved
human beings
are a much worse poison
than schnapps or tobacco
[Music]